okay
for people joining this live stream we
are talking about multi-computation and
wolfram language
and nick has some new things he's done
which
he
was going to show off
so i think i'm actually i should set to
save this in an appropriate place here
excuse me here
um
uh
where was this being saved is this being
served in the research
yes okay
so then sw notes at the bottom near the
bottom
okay
okay
all right so
let's start off so this is
hyper graph multi okay so this is the
state and this is the rules is that
right
yeah so the plan
today i think is
tourist multi-system
with some fresh perspective on it
okay so
and the first idea is just
why not just compile everything into
hyper graphs because it makes much
easier to say like
draw some causality from it
arguments it's an interesting idea
okay we thought we had tree-like
expressions but actually we have
hypergraphs
is that your basic claim yeah yeah that
idea already was explored by max i think
a long time ago
like running
uh wufong language a skype graph writing
right now he had a he had a compilation
to that
yeah um so this is the same basically
the same idea but you can also rewrite
expression strings
graphs
trees we now have trees and even
hypergraphs you can write in this
type of hyper graph when always let me
just let me get used to this idea for a
second okay
so
you know tree structured expressions
have been
you know your basic claim is when you go
to multi-computation
a tree structured symbolic expression is
no longer a natural data structure
instead hypergraphs are a natural data
structure is that the basic claim yeah
and the structure of the hypographer
very computer sciencey this structure is
like every
the idea is that every hypergraph
hyperedge have a link like oh you can
think of it that would have a place in
memory you allocate a place for
hyperedge and the hyperage contains
links that link to other hyperedges yes
and like that's it and the replacement
of hyper edges is just removing some
links
creating some new ones and that's always
what's happening
right which is essentially what we're
doing
i mean
when we deal with symbolic expressions
with the symbol tape well symbolic
expressions
are like that but they have more
structure to them whereas here you're
saying this is a pure
everything is like not a linked list but
a you know a link type of graph
basically
right it's pure pure link realignment
that the
um you can compile three into link
hypergraph
yeah you know your
not gonna link to its children
yes
okay so let's take a look at what you've
got here so that this is now
so
what what are you actually doing here i
see so what you're doing here is you are
your compiler
your core data structure is now hyper
graph and so your string is being the
string here is being compiled into a
hyper graph element
yeah so that you just compile multi here
multi object here is just for
it acts only as some kind of storage for
rules and that's it as soon as you make
a rule
it's a simple rule you can use it like
in whatever framework we have or you can
use it in token when graphs you can use
it in testness graphs
so much
principle is not necessarily needed here
can i ask what is the one a zero mean
it's first turning a character string
into a into a a linked hypograph
yeah so the first
vertex in the hyperage is the address of
this hyperage then it's then what falls
it's payload and then
any amount of links i will demonstrate
here by doing this so it's it's a path
graph
and it has it has one as like its
starting endpoint and zero is its ending
endpoint or something like that yeah
when it's a string it's a path graph
or at least you can compile a list or
string into this kind of linked
simple link hypergraph but you also can
compile any tree
right
so so the characters in the string are
like edge tags
that is correct
okay
right so the middle element
in this hyperedge is the payload
right
but it didn't wouldn't have to be a
payload there that could be
you know in the case of
space
you know these are just
well
i mean the thing that's complicated
there is that the interpretation
of these uuids is atoms of space
yeah and are these stresses
it's a triple when you have a simple
list but when you have a
like an expression that has more than
one child it can have more than one link
that it links to
okay so to hypergraph with general it's
not necessarily a ternary hyper graph
no it's like minimal
it's minimal is two when you have just
another send up payload
or you can just ignore the payload and
principle also allowed
right
okay so let's let's walk through this a
bit so what you're saying is
this has now been compiled into pure
hypograph transformations and then this
is also a hypergraph transformation okay
do you have a function that shows the
hypergraph transformation here
yeah i have just a two link hypergraph
function that does every transformation
you can fit any type
and it will make a hypergraph it can be
a rule just a single row i don't think i
i did it with link with lists
now twist this as a list so just give it
a
single row
okay
so by the way i mean that would fit into
um
maybe
each individual one
just for some context i mean
is the idea that this is how it would
evaluate arbitrary
you know mathematica code or is this
is this just for
i'm not sure totally what this what this
is for
this is arbitrary code i mean this is
the idea is that just as we normally
have an evaluator that's based on tree
walking
why is this not but it seems a little
crazy to use uh
you know to represent it i mean like
right i mean
it seems like like this is a
you know a vastly less at least space
efficient way of representing
expressions
and
and it's not even going to be easy you
know functions like i don't know string
reverse won't just innately work will
they unless it has to reconstruct the
string from this this hyper graph which
seems really
expensive yeah i mean this is look
there's no compiler for this yet i
assume
unless nick is going to pull a giant
elephantine rabbit out of the hat
i mean this is a thing where the
functions it's going to support are
things like slash dot replacement
but so i i is this is this basically a
replacement of you know for example the
uh
uh the the the the um
you know replacement systems the string
substitution systems that were in
multi-way system or is this also a
replacement for the multi-function we
saw the other day which worked with
arbitrary code
and then it falls on the same category
as soon as you compile everything to
hyper graph and you're given a new
hypergraphic writing rule you can apply
it to it that's all what it does it's in
a very inefficient implementation like
you have an explicit addresses but i
presume that how that's actually how
expressions are stored so in principle
we could have a data data structure sure
for any expressions even i mean
i i just think it seems like this is a
fine thing to do for the more abstract
you know string substitution systems
cellular automata maybe you know etc but
that
you know once
if you're doing it for arbitrary code
it's going to be just hopelessly
hopelessly inefficient and efficiency
matters because of course if you have an
arbitrary program and you want to do
this sort of uh non-deterministic
evaluation
that's a very expensive operation and
and if it's going to be running ten
thousand times slower because it's
representing expressions and some in
some hyper graph thing that that's done
in the top level then it's just it's
going to be all right you're making
various assumptions here okay first
point is
the first thing the the principal thing
that we're trying to achieve here is to
understand a new style of computation
different from our tree based fixed
point based single way evaluation
that's the first point
so even if this is not you know in other
words we don't expect necessarily that
this will align what this is good at
will necessarily align with what our
existing technology is good at 1.1 yeah
well no but hold on look there are two
uses of this stuff there is there is
sort of studying kind of you know
studying kind of simple models like
cellular automata like strength
substitution systems like hypergraph
substitution systems etc
and then there's then there's the the
you know programming you know actual
sort of programming version which is
what we talked about a bit more like
last time which was using multi which
sort of inherits a bunch of the you know
built-in deterministic functions but
then it puts sort of non-determinism on
top of them
right these are two different things
this seems fine for the first case of
simple models of non-deterministic
computation it seems impossible for the
second case
but okay the thing is during the last
meeting the first design objective that
we discussed was to reproduce useful
functionality of multi-way system and
its many variants with multi the problem
was it was actually it was difficult to
fully understand what we could do with
multi we needed some way to actually be
able to explore this functionality
stephen was giving various examples of
what we could do but it was difficult
because we didn't have any way of
actually doing it in a clean kind of
consistent way and what stephen said was
just go and try and find a way to do it
it can be inefficient we just need to be
able to have some sort of
some sort of way to discuss this in a in
a more precise way so that's what we
have so why don't we just look at what
nick did yeah we should do that before
we speak
it's setting a little bit more general
context okay
to me
even having a framework that allows us
to unify all of those different
multi-way system functions is useful
the second point is the things that
prologue and the logic programming world
and all that kind of thing has
traditionally been used for the cases
where people say look it's a wonderful
solution for this
if we can get those as well that's a
style of programming that's interesting
moving from that to
and we take i mean it's like people
saying you know
as they did in the 1990s and things you
know i'm going to take your arbitrary
piece of fortran code or that shows the
80s and i'm going to parallelize it
magically
there's a small amount you can do there
and there's a lot that's super hard i
you know i don't think that's what we're
i mean the
to give an extreme analogy the
connection machine computer which was a
four bit processor computer with no no
notion of numbers even
there was you know its original thing
was oh look at all the interesting
computations you can do on it and then
somebody said oh but it has to be able
to run fortran code
and then it was hopeless
so i mean i think i think this is a
perfectly fine thing as basically a a
wrap up of all the multi-way functions
and also generalization of them right
that that makes perfect sense i'm just
saying this is also
you know it's it's not even i don't
think this is really targeting the
second use case which maybe have a
totally separate implementation but that
is what we were talking about the last
few weeks and this is a different thing
so i'm just trying to understand that i
think that is that is for now correct
but we may
learn things from this that are super
useful for the other thing so let's look
at what nick has done yes let's look at
what's what's what's happened here okay
so
the basic concept and what i which i
really like is to clarify what has been
quite muddy which is
what is a causal relationship what is a
you know in
in the language of our
what is an atom of existence what is an
eem
which is you're clarifying here it's
you know in the case of a string it's
not completely clear what the eams
actually are and you're i think
clarifying that is that a fair
characterization nick
well you're saying
for string causal
computation was kind of
tricky because you're when you're doing
the string replacement you're moving all
the right hand side of your string
right in order to actually compute what
was actually caused by what
you have to like run your computation
from beginning
rather than just
storing some what's right whereas for
you every every element here is an atom
of existence
and it's very clear which which atom
affects which other thing is that a fast
statement
yeah it's like an others in memory
you either
store it somewhere you create it and
destroy it
right
but that i mean put it put in a more
physically way it's kind of like an atom
of existence
yeah these are eams
and they have some some some kind of
coordinate where you can understand how
they fit together so to speak
and the payload itself also can be like
canonicalized into the same structure oh
okay okay so every hyper graph has a
canonical version
but but this is could just be in a
symbol table this literal b
could just be a shared b in a symbol
table
effectively so
it's it's the same atom of space that
every every hyper edge links to
right
okay let's let's take a look at what's
happening here
okay so what's happening so you say
so this is just you can you can just run
it multiple times right it's just a
simple
evaluation that the multiple
can do if you just have a rule inside of
it
just run it four times you get new hyper
graphs it's like your
branch or hyper surface
and that's it
here is just for storing the rule you
can done it with anything
you've got an initial condition as well
the stone initial condition in the room
and some other stuff
just a container for your computation
right but it didn't actually do anything
yet yeah
and and then you when you ask for a
graph i used graph here as a as another
data structure mostly like
that all contains all the computation
already
in its text
it's like all the tags in this graph
contains all the information that
happened an actual event information
well this graph contains in
what i mean it's tags in
like every edge here it's like
the point is here that the
mutual system itself if you don't do any
equivalence of states it's just a tree
that's what i'm gonna i'm gonna show you
later you're just converting a
multi-system even when some mergers
happened accidentally by just same cue
you still treat it as a tree
so each event is a single piece of
writing whether it's like
happened in a completely different path
or a different space it's just a single
rewrite
so you have like the
the same number of events as
number of states
okay because it's a tree yep
and right here
so and graph just acts as a data
structure of evolution you can turn it
into a tree if you want
and then you can
all other
notions of graph that we have can be
computed from those graphs or trees it's
like branchial graph
is like another perspective of it
instead of looking at
just some ancestral connections between
states you just
pick any children and just turn them
turn them into a complete graph
right
i didn't understand
so before doing any equivalent if you
don't have a notion of equivalence
between states yet yes the branch of
graph is just a union of some complete
graphs yes indeed and the union is
between children so the branch of graph
you can do it for every tree
basically
right then yes yes and then you apply
your equivalence and it's simple like
replace function like i think i have it
later
if you scroll down
so the edges in the branch you'll graph
are edges between siblings in the tree
it's like the children each node has
some amount of children and you just put
those children in a complete graph
right branchial graphs
just link vertices that in the original
graph have a common ancestor direct
ancestor
which is which is what you're saying
that they're the they're the siblings of
a given parent
all right yep
showing the sibling edges instead of
ancestor edges
right
right so these these things here would
be in a complete graph together
right and then when there's
equivalencing what's going to happen is
that a bunch of nodes that were separate
in the branch or graph will then
kind of
glue together
right okay
okay what is this creature
this is when you glue the initial
multi-way graph
if you
glue it by equivalencing states by
canonicalizing the hypergraph for
example
i see by canonicalizing the hypergraph
we mean
there are atoms of space here
which are different
but the hypergraph
that is formed from that is isomorphic
yeah
right
which is a criterion for the observer so
to speak that's an observer dependent
thing that the the observer is
equivalencing to identical hypographs
even though they're made of different
atoms of space
yeah
okay
so that's this case where your
equivalency function is
were the
yeah were the hypergraphs and their
literals so to speak
um
equivalent
right and here you what you've done
looks like you've canonicalized the
hypograph
to just use one two three four etc
instead of using the
uuids yeah it looks like
much simpler
right what we have already in the w of
our functions
you just ignore the payload to make it
more clear
what canonical is every addresses to
make it
yes no that's what you're doing that's
what that's the graph canonicalization
this is essentially making an index
graph it's like an index hyper graph is
that right
yeah it's a mo it's a little bit more
tricky than that you have to like it
have there is a canonical order of high
pressures so that it's like
no matter how you permute every hyper
edge and how you rename
all the atoms it's still going to be
kind of equalized but the same way right
right
okay so this is what our usual multi-way
graph would give
although i don't know what these
different colors mean
it's just a rule id because we have two
rules
i see which is something we should have
in a multi-way system long ago
yeah so we have two kinds of edges two
kinds of events
right but we don't we don't duplicate
anywhere so the same number of events
that we had
right
right okay
and here we're also not duplicating
anything it's still the same number of
uh
edges that we had when we had
just complete graphs
i think it's like have more much more
information
and the causal graphs are the most
challenging
so you can like
just look at the tooltip for each event
in the causal graph
why is the event labeled by a string
like that
i'm labeling it by just output string i
have an initial event
and
it's just an output of an event so what
we've done previously with strings is
we've labeled a double decker thing
which is the input string on top of the
output string
yeah it won't work in general so it just
picked this representation for now
it works for any kind like for strings
expressions
to just label an event by its output
yeah i think it's enough
because you have a
the same number of events and states if
you
form a graph from a which way system
go ahead but this is so in the token
event graph view of this which maybe
you're going to get to
the tokens here are always the hyper
edges
and then the events
in this case will be that one consumes
two or two tokens to generate two tokens
but maybe you're going to show that
picture
yeah i think i have something
later
what is the transit reduction what's the
interpretation of the transit reduction
i think that's what what we usually do
by default
we not show the original causal graph
also yeah you're right you're right we
show the transit reduction
okay
ah talking about graph
okay i'm confused by why this has
a tripartite as opposed to a bipartite
creature
because it also includes the states it's
more like a glaucoma multiverse system
now
because
i've made a modification to talk on a
graph when you also can include the
states themselves besides the tokens
okay so what's the
um
what's the way that you connect so i
understand how tokens
lead into events
tokens are like chemical reactions you
have some inputs
you have the event and then you have
outputs
right how do the states relate to that
because what you have here is you've got
these tokens leading to a state leading
to an event i'm confused by that well i
thought what
go ahead what i have there is like two
functions an additional two functions
how you would
uh given a state decomposition of tokens
oh it's usually a simple one if you have
just a list of hyper edges it's going to
be identity
each hyper which is a token and
recombination how would you
given every output
token from each event how you will make
a new state from out of it yeah look i
mean you can see right each of the each
of the tokens they feed into the state
so b b and a feed into bba and they then
bba undergoes some sort of
transformation
i don't understand but the
transformation is on tokens it's just
uh
it's i see it
because the recombination function is so
general
it can even be
it can combine tokens from different
states that was as an input so it's not
really
so it's not clear how you would connect
it
with that
so look i think this is a different kind
of edge the edge that's here
look it
i mean this is the challenge this is the
difference between local and global
multi-way systems and so on
is this thing about is it a you know is
it a tokens
is it a token world or is it a um
a states based thing
and those are two different views of
what's going on i think
and i i claim it's going to be very
difficult to put those into one graph
maybe not because like although you're
consuming tokens
and that's a well understood thing every
node
every
every event node is going to have the
same local structure around it
so i'm confused by this picture
because it seems to me that this this is
nick walk me through so you know take
this bba state so we have bba
and there's an event
from so there's an event that goes to a
and then that goes to bbba
um
yeah
that event produced one a number of
tokens one of them tokens was a
and then it just it combines with other
tokens into a new state
and you show states as global states
that they act on the whole state even
though locally they only involved some
number of
tokens not the whole state
is it the case that what's happening
here
is that really
let's see what was the rule here i
thought the rule was just bb
goes to something or other
see that's the point i i think the rule
says was b b goes to something which i
would have accepted there are two rules
a goes to a
b a a goes to b
and
and another one bb goes to
something else
okay but that event there
is
um
that that event there is a bb goes to
something or other event is it not
i don't understand what this is doing
with the a coming in here i would have
expected the bb goes to an event
that then produces
if you remove the states that's what
you're gonna get
okay so can i states are optional
okay how do i do that
well expand one the options to the token
and graph
so we have state vertices goes to true
just
make it close
okay
okay so we've got the a goes so here you
haven't shown the different rules
in any different distinguished way here
but basically yeah that's an a goes to a
b node
and somewhere we'll have a bb goes to
something or other node
um
so that's a bb goes to
what the heck is this why is there a
backward arrow going to the b there
i think it is because
i'm
well that's of this complicated
combination function but it means token
wasn't involved in the rule you have a
state bba right with maybe the state
with three b's but the
event only touched the two b's so you
have to reproduce the one of the
b's that wasn't involved in the rule so
that's what this edge is shown there
jonathan's making a comment here
which i don't understand about cyclists
where is this i'm just commenting on
exactly the same thing you commented on
which is the fact that you've got cyclic
you've got the fact that this graph has
cycles means that it's difficult to
pause
but it's got cycles because
you're somehow reusing a token or no i i
understand why it has cycles but i don't
understand why it has cycles
because of effectively tokenized
impotence of certain events um
but in local multi-way system for
instance we don't we you know we
explicitly remove cycles because they're
kind of it's kind of hard to understand
if you have them
i mean this is called it's a it's a
closed time-like curve because basically
nothing changed in the world
it's a trivial sort of it's a trivial
close-time-like curve because there was
an unchanging some some atom just
reproduced itself
all right
yes
i think i have an option in the token
graph that also removes
cycles like that
so it's also optional whether you want
them or not
okay fair enough but let's keep going
here so we're we're still we're
understanding
okay so i don't completely understand
these state things i i vaguely
understand them and i can't say i
completely understand them
but just together just to frame this
what what is this thing you believe this
is some combination of global i mean
that that's like global state-based
stuff
that's like local multi this is supposed
to be global this is supposed to be
global
i don't know it's just the only
way i found that makes sense to put all
of those in one graph
i think i've tried some bunch of stuff
that like didn't fit it's like when you
connect a state
like
make this graph this three by key graph
token statement token statement
okay but so that the flow the workflow
is
there are a bunch of tokens they combine
into a state see the thing that's
confusing to me is that it's a subpart
of that state that's involved in the
event
but that's not represented by that edge
because it's like hidden
somehow well you can't tag it all the
information is in the tech or in the
event itself what actual tokens will
reveal to them look and when you remove
the state it's there to me what what
should be happening in this graph is
that whatever it is bb goes to whatever
it is should just show up as bb goes
into this event okay
then there should be a lasso so to speak
of various tokens that are somehow
connected together to be re-knitted into
a state
but that's a piece of metadata of the
token event graph isn't it
that's saying there's a token event golf
and everything is happening based on
events to tokens
but somewhere there is also a thing
where you're connecting together
you know sequences of tokens you're
knitting together sequences of tokens
that should be considered as states but
is
how different is that from a foliation
like a local foliation
fully not very different it's not very
different it's the same kind of idea
yes which i think is what
i mean
states in a sense
i mean
you know again these states are in the
eye of the beholder
right so these are like local foliations
by which we get these states i think so
tokens it's an interesting idea okay
okay let's keep going here because i
think something exciting is going to
happen okay
this is again we should discuss the
causal graph do we i think we haven't
okay all right we take too much time on
it yeah okay
it's like how is actually
it was constructed
i also want to like pay attention to the
information that each event has
not just what it was created or
destroyed but it also contains
a position in the original mutual graph
so it's like a branch of position of
this event
so when you actually draw a conclusion
whether two events are causally
connected or not you're not just looking
whether it
the atom the same button was destroyed
that was created by the previous map we
also look whether those events are
occupied the same path and multiverse
system
because why is that relevant
i mean isn't it i'm sorry isn't isn't
causal dependence
are the same atoms of existence
you know
do you depend on an atom of existence
that was used somewhere else
is that not the definition of causality
what what else do you need to know in
causality
i think it's like if you
if you just have a multiverse system
doesn't make sense
to connect
two events from independent paths even
though they maybe involve the same atoms
of space because they are completely i
see like parallel
right so they shouldn't be connected
they should be
you have like
one of the three positions should be a
prefix of another one in order to make a
causal connection
i think in the original multi-way system
that wasn't clear
it's like i had an example when there's
some connection that was
between those branches disconnected
events
just
just because it's like they involve the
same
the same
you know that is a confusing thing i
mean two branches of history that
involve the same atoms in a sense that's
what entanglement is about isn't it
that different branches of history can
involve the same atoms of existence
maybe yeah but like this causal graph
has all events has all of this
information so you can
post process it and
maybe do something like it it's like it
almost has a complete
coordinates
absolute coordinates for each event
i didn't understand the absolute
coordinate idea so that's
in the hypograph i mean so
another point is that there is
let's see i mean
there's a structure
that is just the the ticker tape of all
events that happen
you can just make a list of all the
events that happen there's no notion of
ordering they just just like you can
make a list of of of you know
hyper edges in a hyper graph so
similarly you can just make a list of
events and then there's a knitting
together of those events that's defined
by the content of the events is that the
point you're making
yeah and
i'm also
making a point that it's not just
created and destroyed information but
the original position in the multiple
systems whether those are
branchly disconnected events so much
i understand the claim for the initial
multi-way system i'm i'm unconvinced
that that
i mean i think in the end that's that's
the story of entanglement that that the
that which is on a different branch of
history might still be the same thing
but it's not a part of a causal
graph connection
it's a it's a i see
something else it's a branch
the consequences i mean i remember
nick you didn't include it in this
notebook but you were showing me an
example of a notebook where there was
greater
say causal invariance
under the existing
approach to
to making these cosmographs than this
yeah
as you can see in this example it's
quite ramified which means if you take
this approach obviously it's going to be
much less causal and variance and you
know so if we adopt this for
multi-computation um there are some
implications theoretical implications
for for making noise not causal
invariants
just uh the amount of causal connections
gonna
drop
just because you disconnect all the
branch elements that's it yes
which i think is
has a definite physical interpretation
which is not i mean that that depends on
whether the observer
in some sense spans different branches
of history
if you separate
you know to separate those branches of
history is to
posit that the observer cannot
unify them
which okay let's keep going let's see
what this structurally does
okay so we've now got a combinator
right
into this thing
and this is like an explicit hypergraph
for each combinator
that's amusing
and what's the relationship between the
combination tree and the combinator
hyper graph
i think it's
almost one to one
right if you just make a combinator tree
and compile it into hypergraph that's
the same thing
so if i were to look for example at let
me just see here
um
is it possible to convert a random tree
into a hypergraph
sure yeah let's do it
so let's take a random tree
do you have a tree converter
it's they all called two linked
hypergraph
okay
okay who wants to try to understand this
so we've got a one do you think the tens
are the actual labels here or the tens
of something different
they actually will get the second
element the second element is the
variable
how does it i mean the the
infrastructure is a one
could you explain that that um one of
the others of that
root is the address of that tenth node
and then
four links of all so you have to find
the hyperedge that starts with the two
so you it's the second hybrid and it has
five other panels and it's the first
child of the root node i i think these
are the numbers in a top down depth
first traversal
and then you have linked to four
which is nice so if i draw this hyper
graph
which is seven
you have a link to ten which is one okay
i get it
oh my gosh
stephen can you run that code in chat
yeah
except that i hate the naked variable
there but but um oops
and actually you'll have to specify tree
traversal order
top down
i'm sorry i have to do this
okay
so now what is this going to tell us
this is
i think those are the indices
that two links one two three four
one
has
a payload
and four children
two
has
i'm conf
oh i see we have to compare that with
this here where that was a five
has payload five and one child
three
okay
okay so this is now the
uh
folded up version of this
is that right
what's the relationship between this
nick what what what
the numbers here
are these index numbers right
and sometimes it's a payload because
because actually can we just start
payloading the index numbers could we
make a tree where um uh
ian could i make my
what's that you can just map
map at all to
all the second elements in this hyper
edge map it withhold form or something
or or integer name or something
um we'll just make a whole form
around each second element
for this hyper graph you do map hold
form
give it a hyper graph
and
list of all comma two
and now you do and now you make a motor
pulse
of that
oh i see that's distinguished well i
wish i could see which ones are there
let me not just do a whole form i mean
i'm going to just do framed here
okay
okay so those are the payloads in the
actual
uh tree
and these are the infrastructure nodes
basically
okay so we should be able to read off
the tree
10 goes to through the infrastructure
node
to five
i have a like form linked hypergraph
have a backwards function too
you can give it a hypergraph and
make a tree
okay
okay let's keep going here let's try to
understand this okay so then you're
saying
it's a little bit hard to understand but
you're saying that this
hypograph
so what i was looking for let me just
find one um
ah
see that's a nice multi-way system
um
just just so i understand what's going
on here
so this
whatever this was okay so before we get
to these
those are sk
things again so okay so let's just do
this
okay this is the one
and this
claim is that this
will make a multi-way graph
so here
i'm just trying to understand the
relationship between these things
this thing here should make a
terminating multi-way graph
so there it does nothing
okay
and then what i want to do is i want to
compute graph comma 5 and i don't know
what that thing is doing there
just a vertex shape function
i'm going to do it without a vertex
shape function just to understand what
it does
um
why is it taking so long
because it's gonna be slow
it can be slow
okay all right okay great
so in fact that picture
is encouragingly similar to
this picture here
okay so that is the correct that's the
multi-rate graph
of those combinator rewrites
great
okay now let's understand some of these
things up here so the those combinator
expressions can be compiled into
all right hypergraphs
and then this
is something we've never really had for
combinators which is a good causal graph
is that right
in terms of go ahead it's the same the
same information as above created to
destroy it and the true position
and you can draw all the causal
connections between
events
okay and this is your slightly confusing
states and
yeah
okay let's see what else happens here
what is this x plus one 2x so this is
numerical multi-way system
and this is showing how the expressions
get built up
first as a tree
and then with recombination
all right
good duplication
also can we um
okay so you're deduplicating these
things which are all equal to three
that is the canonical version is that
correct
i mean those two should be equal i don't
understand why those are showing up as
different nodes well they're different
brackets
they're parenthesized differently
okay so they respond to different type
of graphs but but one canonicalization
would be to just say what's numerical
value
yeah for example and that's that's a
canonicalization so i mean you know i
mean that's an interesting observer
thing some observers
might only
um
might only pay attention
to the numerical value
so for example how would i do that so if
i were to do that with
i've got this
hypergraph multi
what am i doing here what are you doing
here
can can we get
okay so now if i do
why is it so slow by the way
so i'm using just my multi replace and
because of your position not hyperedges
it's not just two poisson expressions
i see so it's having to search the hyper
edges every time and things like that
yeah it's like a subset replacement
is it doing is using subset replace
i tried but it turns out it's
rather limited
in the way i wanted it to
in what sense
it's like
the rules that they produce
the contained pattern sequence
and they don't and it's not supported
it's like
in order to
be able to replace arbitrary
like rit
expressions you have to make some kind
of partner sequence pattern
on the left hand side you should
complain to tony about that
um
not the subset replace i meant the set
replace the the actual woofer model oh
okay okay okay
could you use subset replace
which is i think what jonathan has used
okay so this is the
duplicated version how do i deduplicate
with that vertex replace
you just do a vertex to place and
replace each vertex to some canonical
version
oh that's after the fact i want to do it
yeah
can i do it while it's computing so that
i converge vertices while it's computing
yeah
well not really but you have to modify
the rule
okay fine but i mean to me that's an
important point in terms of the general
theory of multi-computation that is
multi-computation
you know in the raw just just generates
trees
multi-computation post-observation has
many equivalences that have been
conflated together
but for efficiency purposes you probably
want to do those conflations on an
ongoing basis not wait till the end
yeah but you have to record it at least
i think that's important information yes
i know that's the thing part yeah and
there are different ways to
conflate i mean in this case of
one plus
one plus one versus one plus one plus
one i mean in in meta mathematics right
we would say that it really depends on
what you have in your entailment cone if
you have some associate associativity
axiom
you're saying the observer pays
attention to the numerical value but i
think what you really mean there is if
this was in an entailment cone with
associativity that yes
these would be equated that's something
that
uh i mean just as a slightly tangential
remark we haven't i don't think we fully
understood is in terms of observing
theory i mean we have foliations
as one example of a choice that
observers can make but i don't think we
fully explored exactly all the different
all the different say choices or
kinds of observer constraints
that lead to
equivalencing i think it's probably
no very complicated yeah and what you're
describing is
in an entailment cone in an entailment
fabric rather
the mathematician observer has a
collection of facts in their bag so to
speak
that they are using
to
knit together a fabric
to for example equivalence those
different associativity you know there's
different
so yeah the fabric is going to be
composed of the cones and the cones are
going to include
axioms or if we're extending this beyond
metamathematics which is interesting
which we haven't really thought about
fully
thinking about fabrics in general for
observers what exactly those cones are
where you're introducing
well look we know the example
for for
pressure measurement okay which is
you've got a great big
you know baffle paddle whatever it is
that many molecules are hitting and we
know that the equivalent thing we're
doing is it doesn't matter where the
molecules hit all that matters is how
many of them hit
so that's an analogy
to what in mathematics would be an
associativity axiom
that's just saying there's an
equivalencing
of all those different molecular
configurations that all just have the
same momentum transfer well that's that
is good food for thought the idea that
the general kind of transductions like
in this case it's like instrumentation
with measurement these general kind of
transductions in observer theory
that we might turn to the case of axioms
and x axiomatic mathematics as a kind of
a
an analog for how to meta-model those
that is interesting i had not thought
about that before yeah i didn't know
that jonathan had a comment can you say
what you were
no i was sorry
what you were saying seemed
unnecessarily confused um i mean so in
mathematics the equivalence function is
just based on whether or not a branch
pair resolves at some point in the
future right that that's the general
case of what you were talking about it's
not unnecessarily confused because what
we're discussing is
is observer theory and we're not just
discussing it in mathematics we're
discussing it in general how this
applies to multicultural i won't
understand what jonathan just said so
i understand the conversation yeah i
mean jonathan is making the point that
if
that all these entailment cones and all
this kind of thing
one way to say it is will it ever will
these ever become equivalent
will these will these two things
if you have the associativity axiom
in your collection of things that
then then one statement is
will these ever become equivalent
as opposed to what i was saying was
you know
if you yeah i mean
jonathan's point is go ahead and the
point you were making about the
relationship between axioms and what are
essentially just course screenings and
measurement theory is a case of exactly
the same phenomenon
right your measurement apparatus is a
lossy function that eq that essentially
sends you know many many different
possible configurations of the universe
to a value to a single observable value
and so then again you're saying that you
know you measure
two systems to be in the same state if
and only if subject to that additional
set of rules
you know a given branch pair will
resolve at some point in the future
exactly yes i agree with you can we just
clarify that a second i agree with that
basic comment but let's take the example
of pressure measurement
where you've got this big paddle thing
okay
um
walk me through what is the
let's see what is the function
i i understand that in the end
what's going to happen is that there's
an attractor that causes all those
different microstates to end up in the
same total momentum transfer
right so so as i say all you i mean this
is the this is essentially the formal
definition of what it means to be a
piece of measurement operators right
it's a lossy function on the space of
possible states
yes i understand but you're saying
you could imagine something like you
know for the case of
you know to construct a minimal example
of your pressure case you could imagine
a string substitution system in which
you know every
appearance of the a character
corresponds to a particular molecule and
then you have a sort of meta rule
uh well i mean it's just a rule but it's
not a rule of specific string to
specific string but rather a string
pattern to a string pattern that would
just say you know map every string with
three a's in it to the number three or
something
and then you know obviously again now
your equivalence function just becomes
will a given branch pair converge at
some point in the future given you add
that additional axiom to your system
okay so the basic point you're making
there is
that you're making the claim an
interesting claim
that a good meta model of a measuring
apparatus is a pattern
transformation rule
well specifically it has it has to be a
lossy function
right if it just sends the same the
space of state to something that's the
same size then you're not performing a
measurement yeah right but i mean a
typical case if you say
right
so you're saying
as a minimal model for our measuring
device
we
i mean so that's a that's a way to to
compile measuring devices basically
to
you're saying that the the
which which has already been done in
some of the mathematical aspects of the
physics project
um
example
well the the general compilation of
permit like commission operators in
quantum information theory to multi-wave
rules for instance which is the topic of
i mean a couple of papers
explain
i mean i i think i understand but can
you can you say more explicitly what you
the
well i mean in that case it's it's
really simple what the lossy measurement
rule is right you've got you've got some
branchial graph
you add rules that map not you know
neighboring branch or graphs to
neighboring vertical graphs but rather
vertices on the same branchiograph to
each other
so now rather than having unitary
transformations that are you know
reversed under edge flipping you have
permission transformations that remain
the same under edge flipping
and that allows you to parameterize an
arbitrary well at least an arbitrary
hermitian operator so an arbitrary
quantum measurement
so what do you think i mean to skip
around a little bit what do you think
for an actual physically implementable
measurement what constraints are there
on that
on that term transformation rule i mean
just like we have kind of the go ahead
there's some trivial ones right like
one would expect that for instance your
lossy measurement function can't violate
causality
right so so you know to take again the
example to take the pressure example you
could count a's in a particular
substring
that's sort of bounded by some light
cone but you couldn't count a's across
the global string
for instance yes
um like
yeah there's a pretty clear like
necessary set of conditions uh
you know needed to define a physically
plausible measurement
but i think it would be interesting i
mean so we were looking see we were
starting to look at actual measuring
devices
and how they actually work
and trying to you know see what is the
you know causality is one
constraint
but it's like you know what is the
analog of computation for measurement so
to speak
what's the analog of the turing machine
this is a different project i know the
project i know it's a different project
i know it's a different project so i'm
just i'm just being greedy if maybe
we'll solve that one at the same time as
this one
but i think the important point here is
that what nick is revealing
is that which we sort of already knew
is that knowing what it is that you're
trying to compute
that computing everything in this tree
of possibilities
is very computationally i mean that is
the ultimate n
you know non-deterministic computation
story
but the conflation process is more of an
art
because it is more of an you know it's a
more of an observer-dependent art
now in other words what conflation you
can do depends on what your final you
know kind of answers you want to get
that makes sense
it's not going to be a thing
there's there's not going to be a
general
pure algorithmic optimization of these
trees it's going to depend on what kind
of observation you want to get out i
believe
do you agree with that claim
there's no general
you know in other words in the end
you're going to coarse screen you're
going to uh you know have a contractive
mapping whatever else it is but the
point is to apply that contracted
mapping
uh sort of
you know
during the computation
rather than have to wait to the end
now in quantum mechanics
that's actually not how it works right
in quantum mechanics the usual
assumption is
you do what you do inside the system and
then you measure it
i don't know in modern
okay this is my ignorance of modern
quantum information theory but are there
serious situations in which you have
intermediate measurement
that is part of the computational
process or is it mostly
and that's the whole basis of like
one-way quantum computing right where
the measurement is actually doing the
computation
explain
well so in one way quantum computing you
prepare a maximally entangled resource
state and your comp so rather than
starting off with the with a with a sort
of pure unentangled uh thing and then
and then doing a unitary operation and
then applying a commission operator at
the end you start with some maximally
entangled thing with a very very
complicated you know intensive product
structure
uh and then you just do sort of single
qubit or or multi-qubit measurements on
it and those the application of those
permission operators is the performance
of your computation so you get a sort of
irreversible version of quantum
computation
is that i mean to what extent is that
like a one-way pad in cryptography where
you've just where you've made this very
complicated thing and you're just biting
off little pieces of it
or is it different from that is this
i guess it's similar but i mean like
one-way pads are
i mean
i get work at a high level the key to
distinction is that one-way paths are
kind of only really a theoretical
interest in cryptography whereas that
you know one-way constant computers are
i mean there are at least people who
claim to have built them
so how do you make the entangled state
physically i don't know
okay but these hermitian operators is it
like could you implement a turing
machine by doing this hermitian operator
then this one then this one or is it
but but of course the you know the key
thing about it is that you couldn't for
instance revisit previous states on the
tape
i see
so in that sense it's like a one-time
pad
yeah right right
that doesn't strike me as being quite i
mean because because what i was
wondering was
you know if we knew enough about the
fine structure of it i mean okay so i've
been learning a little bit about the
actual physics of quantum computers
um and
you know and there's a lot of weirdness
and hokiness there but that's a
different issue the
this question of whether you can insert
measurement in the middle of the middle
of the thing and not just blow the whole
system up
and what you're saying is this is an
example your
your
what did you
mean that they are independent questions
right because if you just had
if you had if you imagine chaining
together like you know like a sort of um
exact sequence in algebra or something
where you know the the output of a of an
ordinary quantum computation now becomes
the input of a one-way quantum
computation yep
then this is
more or less the equivalent of a
multi-way system where you do merging
intermediately rather than just at the
end yes i agree
but one concern that i have is that for
anything that's multi-computationally
irreducible i don't see what trying to
make the equivalences during the
computation really buys you as opposed
to just doing them after the fact if you
don't know at any given successive step
what kind of mergings are possible under
some given merging regime i don't really
understand
what benefit is afforded by doing it in
real time as opposed to post-processing
because we live in real time
that is if we're trying to you know if
we're trying to replicate things like
our experience of nature
saying
let's wait until the end of the universe
and see what kind of complicated
entangled quantum state was produced
and then our future descendants will
read it
you know that's what you're essentially
saying there fine okay so if you want to
if you want to meta-model the observer
well this is this
also a fundamental question about
gravitation right this is the question
what we have done in all the computation
that we've done it's been input to
output computation
it has not been intermediately observed
computation
right and again for the universe the
input to output computation
is not the one that we existed so to
speak i get it so there would be
something like it's almost like having
an observer event where it's like
between updates
you also have some some
observations being performed on it where
it's being coarse-grained and the and
this is just being iterated right and i
i think what nick was doing there in the
states
recombination is something tantamount to
that
right
that is that that's like right
so i mean
that's interesting
you know which is reminds one of
jonathan's you know completion
processes
for quantum measurement
i think
does it remind one of that that is that
somewhere in the middle of this you know
token event golf whatever else it is you
do a completion which is an out of
out of rules
it's a it's a different thing that
wasn't directly what was specified by
the rules it was
all you're talking about here is just
the the idea that you know
state equivalence functions and course
gradings are really the same thing which
i think we've known for a while and it
just so happens that completions are a
very general way to impose both
concepts
i agree that state equivalence functions
of course screening i agree with all of
those statements
so
but are we saying anything new here
we're trying to clean up the concepts
that's that's that's the um
i mean
the idea that doing multi-computations
and including some way of meta modeling
observers where we're actually
introducing
the course grainings
you know in a way that's endogenous to
the computation as it's being run that's
certainly new
this is awesome i haven't heard about
things before okay it is a
in the
it depends on your definition of newness
and it depends on how much computational
irreducibility you allow between the
idea and the conclusion
the um
it's um
uh
certainly the idea of having endogenous
core screenings in multi-way systems is
not as far as i'm aware a new idea
don't right now i mean we don't haven't
implemented that except for completions
right and jonathan you've implemented
things like this with completions in
multi-way systems right
but completions are a general way of
imposing canonicalization of states on a
branch like hypersurface i mean this is
the same
problem
um so you're saying by completions
you mean
i mean
by definition let you impose arbitrary
equivalences on states on a given branch
like hypersurface right
well let's let's unpack that for a
second unless you unless you're using
some notion of course graining that's
different from anything wait a second
wait a second
a completion
takes two branches on a branch pair
and can conflate them right now
it takes two states
on a branch like hypersurface and
imposes an equivalence relation between
them
fine but let's take our
and then we bring in you know we wheel
in a measuring apparatus from the next
door lab
and it's a different set of you know it
brings new rules into the system
doesn't it
that are not the same
it's possible that the conceptual basis
of all of this has changed since i was
last involved in these discussions but
um
a measurement again like a measuring
apparatus is a is a lusty function it's
a core screening
system right so it will take
a collection of possible states of some
system and it will produce equivalence
classes of them that have the same
observable value
yes yes
just taking a branch like hypersurface
imposing an arbitrary equivalence
relation on it
yes
and completion the reason for
investigating completion was that that's
an operational way to do that by just
incorporating new rules in the system
okay but if there are arbitrary new
rules i agree with you if they're new
rules that specifically come from branch
pairs that's a more specific case is it
not
well why because
the
if though if you can connect if you can
complete an arbitrary pair of states on
a branch like hypersurface you could
impose an arbitrary equivalence relation
between states on a branch like
hypothesis there's i mean i should just
say there's no there's no content in
that your claim is that everything came
from the big bang eventually
and the question is and these two things
would normally be completely different
places in branch
branch hill space
and
your your basic statement is but if i
can but if i can add edges that connect
them and make them neighbors then they
don't anymore and that's
what right but the meta point there
which was a little different from the
way i was thinking about it is
assume everything comes from the big
bang so everything is coming from the
same place
then all that you need to do then
everything's going to be on that branch
like hypersurface
and then it's a question of just picking
two things and and gluing them together
as opposed to the way i was thinking
about it as we were talking about it
previously with
which is
there's a kind of a
uh
yeah i mean you're right that insofar as
the things that exist in the world
all come from all are all there
somewhere all the things that can exist
in the world are somewhere on that
branch like hypersurface
therefore all measurement can ever do is
to of course graining can never do is to
conflate things in different places on
that hypersurface therefore you can
always think of that as being something
where you are conflating things that
branched at some point in the past
that's the measurement the least i've
had for the last
three years or whatever
um
there's a certain i i'm now going to be
big on this computational irreducibility
of ideas that is how far do you have to
go
i mean yeah anyway the the um
right i would say
um in relation to the stuff we were
discussing right in the beginning about
the hypergraph computation uh
compilation stuff there is an
interesting conversation to be had about
using
hypergraphs to represent kind of
generalizations of expressions
that
relates to a whole bunch of cte stuff
and other things
explain
by ct we we
we unpacked that to category theory
right i mean so for instance like in the
in the framework that we're currently
developing for the handling to save
string diagrams and humanitarian
categories those are already like a
generalization of ordinary expressions
and then there's the formalism of
kissinger fong with hypograph categories
that's a generalization of that which
eventually i'd like to implement because
it's relevant to the
uh you know categorical quantum
mechanics business
um and so yeah that's that's an even
further generalization of what it means
to be an expression and that
in one
are you having to generalize the notion
of expression for the string diagrams
okay so so with an ordinary expression
right why is it a tree well it's a tree
because your
sub expressions are all effectively
many-to-one functions right you have you
know f of x y so you have x y going into
a single value f
okay
i i wouldn't necessarily think of a
function that way but yeah okay let's
take it as that yes i mean yeah yeah
but you could now imagine having a uh
you know a mini valued version of that
right we have a you have
x y goes to f but f actually produces
two you know which is f one of x y and f
two of x y or something
so now you haven't now you haven't got a
tree you've got a dag
and that's effectively the structure of
an ordinary string diagram right so you
you take some ordinary category with
ordinary notions of function composition
and you induce a tensor product
structure that lets you chain together
multi and then you kind of glue together
multiple objects so you can produce many
argument functions and also glue
together the output so you get many
valued functions and that gives you a
string diagram
which is just a tag or i mean there are
versions of it where you can have cycles
but a bit more complicated what's the
relationship between that dag and a
token event graph
where the functions are the events
well i mean
the there is a one-to-one correspondence
between minotaur string diagrams and uh
well multi-ua systems which are
themselves just you know representable
as token event graphs
uh
again this has been explored um
in previous some detail right
um
and then yeah so there's so hypograph
categories and therefore hypergraph
string diagrams are gener in turn
generalizations of those kinds of
monolithic categories where now you can
have an output of a single sub
expression appear in multiple
uh sort of potentially hierarchically
nested
uh you know super expressions
and so now your edges are not edges
anymore they become hyperedges
um wait a minute wait wait wait wait so
you're saying
okay so in one way to think about
the evaluation of an expression is to
work up from the bottom of the tree and
you keep on having these merges where
arguments of functions become values of
functions
and functions have a single output value
right now you can yeah
but now so now imagine you've got the
case which is again like a
generalization of the of the
many valued case where you've got you
know f of x y is a sub expression of
some larger thing
yeah that uses f x y as an argument
somewhere
yeah but then
there's a super expression of that which
also uses the same f of x y that's not
permitted an ordinary expression tree
it's not even permitted in an ordinary
string diagram but it would be permitted
in a hypergraph string diagram
because now you've got your um
now you've got an edge which has you
know
you have two hybrid edges you've got one
that's sort of that's got x f and
some future thing all in one edge and y
f and some fusion of thing all in one
edge
right so you're saying that one
possibility is that
f and x and y which are sort of atoms
can appear at nodes of this thing but
you would also like it to be the case
that a whole sub-expression can be a
node
is that right
uh well again that that already happens
in expression trees effectively right
once you've once you've got the sub tree
for fxy then wherever f goes it
represents f x y
yes okay
all right so what's the new thing
say that again what what's the new
case
you get the difference between an
expression tree and an expression dag
right
yes i mean one has common shared common
sub expressions that are being
represented as single nodes and the
other has them unrolled as different
tree elements
no
no no so even in the case where they're
unrolled there's a generalization of
what it means to be an expression
which is what a string diagram which is
what oh yeah okay which is which is your
thing where you have different values
where you have your f1 and f2 as
different outputs from the function
right right so so so in the ordinary
expression tree case you just have a you
know you just have
a three vertex two edge tree where
you've got f x and y
but in the two argument case you've now
got you know an x and a y coming into a
node and then and then an f one and f
two coming out of that node so it's no
longer a tree it's a it's a directed
acyclic
uh but you can go a step further than
that and you could say well now imagine
i've got
now imagine the so ordinarily f will
only appear as a sub expression in one
super expression right
what's f now there's f1 and f2 what's f
yeah i mean f is a multi-valued function
so you can okay
all right okay so f is like the event
and it has an f1 and f2 branch coming
out of it
sure and so if you wanted to think about
it in terms of you know
global multi-way systems or something
then
the case of hypergraph categories would
correspond to one in which a single
event can causally influence more than
one future event
but um in the way it's normally thought
of in the sort of formalism of the stuff
uh yeah so a hypergraph category would
correspond to one in which f can appear
as a the same f can appear as a sub
expression in multiple super expressions
okay why isn't that a common
sub-expression story
well there's a common subject expression
is one where it appears in one super
expression and then there's sort of
nesting
right okay
okay
the f could appear in two
sub-expressions that are not nested
they're not related it's just the same f
appearing in two places
they're branchingly related
but not
okay right but not time-like related
yeah or tree-like related or whatever
right
yeah
so that would be a hypograph category
because now your string diagram is not a
dag anymore it's now one
now wait i'd like to i have another
question
um
about what we were discussing before in
terms of observatory theory so
i understand jonathan what you're saying
we can meta-model observers more
generally by instead of thinking about
say
axioms that we're including in some
entailment cone
in the meta mathematics case we can just
consider generally that observers have
you know certain completion rules that
they're applying to some
multi-computation in order to
in order to um in order to coarse grain
problem is as stephen said before
this is sometimes described as
how did steven put it he said
you know
we have a multi-computation and how
exactly you coarse grain depends on what
exactly the observer wants to extract
from the from the overall system more or
less right
maybe the observer wants to extract some
some kind of bulk or aggregate property
from the system they're going to apply
some sort of completion rule in order to
do so but the difficulty is
especially if if if multi-computational
irreducibility is at play where you
don't exactly know what kind of merging
behavior you're going to get you can't
really say
uh beforehand what kind of completion
rules are going to apply right it could
be the case that you there's some
behavior and you say okay here's an
opportunity to perform this kind of
completion i'm going to introduce this
kind of rule and then the behavior is
more uh complex than you expect it to be
and you think okay well let's introduce
this completion rule the trouble is the
observer is going to be bounded to some
resp to some extent you can't just
introduce you know some large number of
completion rules um so we're saying you
know
you introduce the observer is going to
coarse grain to the degree that they
want to
they want to the observer has what they
have and the observer is some measuring
device or us or whatever else and we
have a certain bag of tricks
and those are what we get to use right
so the evolution of human technological
progress is in some sense that we're
slowly able to add
completion rules to the way that we're
yes but that's not that's not something
that's easily done
no i mean that that is the nature of
abstraction and other such things
exactly
right these things that look different
are actually could actually be treated
as the same well for some time i've
wanted to understand because we always
describe
observers as being computationally
bounded and i've been fishing for
you know some instance in which we can
say okay here's an example of in a meta
model how we can actually uh model
whatever constraints are placed on the
observer and i think the fact that the
observer has some limited number of
completion rules is one example of a
kind of observer budget that they have i
think jonathan wanted to make a point
i mean if okay if we want to get if we
want to be philosophical about this i i
kind of think it's the other way around
right
my position has always been that the
definition of what
what it means to be an observer is that
you are a computationally bounded entity
within some multi-way system yeah and
the notion of observation emerges as a
consequence of the fact that you have to
impose equivalence relations right if
you're going to make sense of what's
actually going on
right so it's not that
the
number of completion rules is somehow a
budget for our observation it's the the
condition of necessity as a consequence
of a pre-existing budget that comes from
computational boundedness i kind of feel
like this is
well i mean that has a very practical
consequence which of those is right
which view of those is right i i suspect
that it meets somewhere in the middle
that is yeah yeah right that that we
have you know in our eyes or whatever we
are aggregating you know photons hitting
different photoreceptors and so on and
we're also
um
and that's the sense in which we have a
certain
right but also we're not capable
of having
you know we only have a certain budget
of okay think about it this way we have
you know 10 million fibers in our optic
nerve or something that's the total
amount of stuff we can deliver from the
eye to the brain
but now
so that's our kind of limit that's
jonathan's version of we only have a
bounded amount of stuff that we can be
dealing with well our bounds go in two
ways right one is there's a certain
degree of verification that we can't
achieve but we can use instruments
um to to be able to achieve some kind of
verification that we that we don't
usually have because we're bounded
there's also abstractions where it takes
a certain amount of computational effort
to coarse grain more than we would
naturally so i think we're i think the
default state is we're in some kind of
mediocre middle we could get a more
uh we could get a more granular degree
of resolution that requires some some
work we could get a more abstract view
that also requires some work to go in
either direction i think
but i
think that
there may be although there may be
sociological reasons to make that
distinction i don't think there are any
particularly fundamental reasons to make
that distinction i kind of view them as
being both part of the same thing that
both in the natural measurement that we
have to do that's evolutionarily imposed
and in the induced measurement that
comes about from greater levels of
abstraction or thinking you know
improved thinking tools or better
measurement apparatuses they're both a
consequence of wanting to basically take
the kind of wild untamed computation
that occurs naturally and turn it into
something that's kind of entrained and
and uh tailored to specific human
purposes right
i agree but what i had my it's not a
sociological distinction it's trying to
trying to understand
you have some observer if the observer
is doing additional work to
change the kind of observations that
they perform trying to understand what
this means in terms of adding or maybe
even removing rules i mean if you're
getting a more resolute if you're
getting a more granular picture maybe
that involves actually removing some
some some rule
and maybe
achieving greater abstraction involves
adding more i'm not exactly sure how
this works but the point is that
you could
an observer might be interested in doing
both
i'm not trying to make i'm trying not
trying to create sociological or
philosophical categories i'm trying to
think about how we're going to
meta-model the observers with respect to
these completion rules well we've got a
very practical point here which is in
next formalism
if we are going to try to prevent it
from just exponentially treely blowing
up
we have to have some kind of uh
conflation process
yes we're amortizing that conflation
process in terms of completion rules
seems like a possible thing to do
in other words one could imagine
nick does that make any sense to you i
mean so in other words if you say
yeah so you're giving a certain set of
rules
i'm a little bit i don't i don't
i don't agree that so those
should be somehow
uh external to the multiverse system is
the observer is a part
of the evolution itself it's somehow
computationally
intrinsic
those are also intrinsic to the
computation
so we've never done some
i know what you're peeling off i mean
let's take this example here what you're
going to peel off is a picture of this
it might have started as a tree but what
you peel out of it is the coarse grained
equivalenced
thing that depends that has only numbers
at nodes and isn't a tree
yeah but peeling off that mean the the
computation that happens inside of the
observer
yes that rotation the his reconstruction
of the multiverse system was it sees it
after the conflation that
exactly but my point is that as a
practical matter
in using this as a practical
computational tool we're going to have
to do internal conflation
because otherwise the things just kind
of blow i mean look the universe
you know one of the things we have to
come to terms with is the universe is
just an outrageous
profligate waster of computation
you know it's probably it's you know we
can think of it as treeing out all these
things there's no equivalencing going on
it's just spewing out different
possibilities
right but we as observers of that
are
doing all these conflations
and
our models
our useful models of the universe do
involve
mergings
i mean in some intrinsic ontological
something or other sense
maybe the universe isn't merging at all
it's just that with respect to any of
our experiences of the universe it is
merging
and my point is
how deep do you
put that merging
inside the computational process that
you're doing
to
you know do multi-type stuff right
because if you if you keep the merging
only at the edge to use a different
analogy from you know from the from
computation
you know if merging is only at the edge
there's an awful lot of stuff that
happens that has to happen in the middle
so the issue would be to move merging
away from the edge
and into the interior
right
and then the question is
you know to parametrize
that
you know
i think that merging moving merging away
from the edge and into the interior is
deeply entangled not i don't mean that
in a literal sense
with traversal orders and foliations and
things like this
because
you know
defining a foliation
it doesn't make any difference if if all
you're doing is the interior you don't
care what the foliations are you just do
what you do and eventually you'll do
everything and so on there's no there's
no but foliations become important when
you want to have waypoints
and the confusing part about the whole
thing is that our experience of the
universe is based on those waypoints
it's not an input output experience
it's a you know journey type experience
so
you know again we're pushed back into
realizing that
i mean i i think we should look at some
particular parameterizations and and i
claim this is deeply related to the
thing i keep on yakking about of you
know probabilistic programming versus
logic programming versus whatever else
these are all
as an efficiency hack okay every one of
those could be done at on the edge
but as an efficiency hack
they also need to be done in the
interior i claim
in other words it could be the case that
everything is lazy right up to the point
where you're on the edge and you're
doing a measurement
um but in fact
for practicality i mean and that's
related to you know back in the i don't
really know this stuff very well in
logic programming you know cuts and all
this kind of thing i don't really know
how those work but but this concept that
you don't
you don't just tree everything out
i like theorem provers as well same same
same story
um
right i mean the the thing that james
was talking about earlier about how
there was some fundamental
reconcilability between you know the
glowing things at the edge versus
glowing things in the intermediate that
just doesn't exist when you're say
traversing a proof tree right the way
the way that a
a um
okay something like vampire the way that
it traverses proof trees is it will go
you know until you get a critical pair
resolution
effectively until you get a branch
resolution and then it will just
equivalence out all branches that led to
that branch power solution so it's kind
of doing retrospective retrospective
state equivalence based on you know
future
essentially intersection of entailment
codes this is a fairly standard idea
but
so okay so your point is
the
the equivalence of observation on the
edge to observation in the interior
there is presumably a calculus of
what types of observation on the edge
can be interiorized
it's not self-evident what you can do i
mean you could imagine
a a measurement on the edge that was not
interiorizable
right i mean this
in a in a slightly
modified form this is a fairly central
question in categorical quantum
information theory
because essentially what this
distinction of whether you do treeing
out whether you do pure treeing or
whether you have equivalences is really
the distinction of whether the tensor
product structure on these straight if
you think of these now as string
diagrams whether the tensor product
structure is purely cartesian or whether
it's some you know something some
deviation from a pure cardiovascular
intensive it's more like a chronic
product
and so then in effect what the question
about you know do you do equivalencing
on the edge versus on the interior
becomes the question if you've got some
you've got some very
you've got some very complicated looking
cartesian product in some in some smc
and you want to say well can i turn this
into a what's an smc
symmetric window or category the setting
first
um and so and you want to you want to
ask can i turn this into some very
complicated looking chronic style tensor
product with certain properties and then
there are cases in which you can do that
and there are cases in which you can't
and what that translates to is can i
glue the
vertices of this diagram together in
such a way that you know i obtain a you
know a tensor product structure with
with these axioms satisfied right and i
think in in terms of language of
ruleology slash meta modeling
steven is the point you can't do it you
can
if it's the case that you can only do a
measurement on the edge so to speak it's
because the multi-computation was
sufficiently multi-computationally
irreducible that you weren't able to you
weren't able to make any equivalences
yeah it's a good way to put it i mean
that that's you know you've been pushing
this idea james of multi-computational
irreducibility
which is and that's i think this is a
good case of it i mean that is can you
you know a reduction is can you go from
the edge into the interior
if you cannot it's a sign of
multi-computational irreducibility right
and there might very well be some a
nice uh
category theory category theory way of
uh well which is what jonathan is saying
i mean one is a convenient product that
is that you just you have that and it's
only modular modding out happens after
the fact and the others you can write it
as
incrementally you can write it as
something which isn't a cartesian
product and already has that
equivalencing happening right
which is so
that question
of whether so so what's an elementary
mathematical example of this of where
you have things and they're they're
producting out
and then
at the end i mean there's there's got to
be some example just with numbers
where you just say
you know at the end
like like for example
a random example i don't know why this
one comes to mind you remember that
tropical algebra thing i think jonathan
i think you were working with some
students
from 2018 or something yeah right i mean
which is
and remind me that that that's where the
way instead of taking
even more
you've got a max plus algebra right so
you're you've got it you produce a semi
ring where your addition operation is uh
the max operation and your
multiplication operation is ordinary
edition right i have no idea why it's
called tropical but let's not worry
about that because because one of the
people who developed it lived in brazil
that's that's uh terrific
okay that's that's useful um the okay so
anyway the the um
but is that a case where again i can
imagine something where you do a
computation with numbers and then you're
maxing things out at the end
but there isn't a way to
sort of well actually here's an example
here's an example so
if you do with with mod numbers and
you're doing ordinary arithmetic it
doesn't matter whether you work with a
finite field
and you do that all the way through the
computation
or whether you compute with huge numbers
in the intermediate stages and then at
the end you mod it out
did that make any sense
i mean if i if i take you know just some
random computation okay if i take um
uh morphism
[Music]
what's that it's a group homomorphism
yes probably
um
i don't know the um
you know let's say i do this and i'm
uh
okay i go ten steps here right and i've
got big numbers and now i go i say mod
that comma 11.
okay i've got my numbers there now
that's in this particular case
that is equivalent to just saying he
says not actually knowing that's true
but i think it's true isn't it
yeah that's true but that's not always
true for every
for for some measurement operations
like this
this would not be internalizable in this
way
is that right i mean like like i was
thinking this topical case might be
maybe it isn't i don't know but
there's plenty of things i could do here
like i could say
i don't know what's the um uh you know
how many prime factors do these numbers
have there's no way i can internalize
that in this way
i think this is fairly obvious right
but doing mod 11 is a homomorphism from
the additive group of the integers to
the um
cyclic group
okay
and but okay so you're claiming this
some homomorphism it's a commuting of
operators in some ways do you apply the
the mod before you do the addition in
the first
group
right or do you apply the mod okay okay
that's practically the definition of a
hollow
yes okay i get it
right
well okay there's more to understand
here and i'm unbelievably late for
something else so we probably should rap
but nick that great work in this in this
idea about hyper graph
compilation this looks very
fertile and i think we are you know we
lots of things are converging here and i
think the thing that um
uh
you know to christopher's point about
the practicality of doing this as a
practical evaluation scheme we're not
there yet we need to explore this
with respect to specific functions like
uh you know replacement rules and so on
and see how that works
and it will be good to i mean there's
clearly
i really think it's worthwhile to start
parameterizing these kind of
measurement operators or whatever you
call them
um
and just see how internalizable some of
those things are
and how much they can
you know increase the efficiency of what
nick is doing
which otherwise you we're going to have
a problem with because
treeing things out is ultimately not
efficient
so the question is you know if it even
if it's a theorem proving you know way
of doing it like jonathan's comment
about vampire you know
eating its way back up it's
that must be somewhat similar to many of
these they're improving i mean in the
end well in the end
with most theorem proving you're working
from the answer you know you have a you
got a giant treeing out that could
happen but in the end you know what the
answer is and you're going to to find
the proof you're going to be working
backwards from the answer
um
anyway okay i have to run but this was
great
thanks everybody
and um
uh
uh